Cameron why don't you try drawing the
critical rendering path diagram for this
example sure let's see first things
first we request this HTML then we start
to build the DOM and come across this
CSS file which of course we have to
request we continue to build the Dom and
then immediately encounter a pas which
is parser blocking so we halt
construction of the Dom request and wait
for the file when we finally get the CSS
and have built the CSS aam we can run a
pas and then continue to build the DOM
and then we hit the next script timing J
s so we've locked parsing on the
download does that sound right yep
that's right however this could take
quite a while first we block on Apogee s
and wait for it to arrive then on timing
GS and wait for that to arrive to
optimize this particular case the
browser has a special process called the
preload scanner which Peaks ahead in the
document and tries to discover critical
CSS and JavaScript files like timing da
GS oh that's clever so even though the
parser is blocked we could discover
timing j s and initiate downloads for
critical resources yeah exactly so
instead of waiting to build the CSS
object model and run app da GS before
requesting timing on GS the preload
scanner finds timing da GS and requests
said while the parser is blocked cool
well that's pretty interesting where can
I learn more about the preload scanner
check out the instructor notes you'll
find a couple of good resources there
that will help explain why the preload
scanner exists and how it operates